for nearly a decade the birthday parties
for lawrence brooks weather on his porch
in new orleans during the pandemic
you know you're my hero or at the
national world war ii museum thank you
god bless we're must see celebrations
the oldest world war ii veteran died
this week at the age of 112.
brooks who was also thought to be the
oldest person in america served from
1941 to 1945 when the military was still
segregated brooks was in the pacific
theater during world war ii with the
mostly black 91st engineer battalion he
was a reluctant soldier opting instead
to work as a cook in his unit
he made it through the war and after
returning home to new orleans faced the
challenge of the jim crow south
then more than a half century later when
he was in his 90s
hurricane katrina threatened his life
and took his wife's hurricane katrina
took everything out one
washed away everything
and yet you survived that too yeah i
survived that too
yeah
the lord was just good to me
he often shared his secret to a long
life with anyone who'd asked including
me when i spoke with him on his 110th
birthday what is the secret to your
success
i always
love people i love people
he was one great big bundle of love that
guy he's just incredible explain you
smoked him at 110.
he was rolling too yeah i got the
assignment i was like well are you sure
they're like trust us perfect person yes
yes